Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Mais bonjour. Vous êtes très nombreux et nombreuses à avoir écouté l'épisode avec Alice Coffin il y a deux semaines et avoir découvert Septante Minutes Avec par la même occasion.
Donc déjà, bienvenue à tous et à toutes. Ma conversation avec Alice était bien évidemment hyper centrée sur la France. Cette semaine, on vire à cent quatre-vingts degrés puisque je discute avec le sociologue Renaud Maes de prostitution.
Et vous verrez que la conversation est par moments assez centrée sur la Belgique et même sur Bruxelles.
Autre précision, l'épisode est un peu plus long que d'habitude parce qu'entre l'enregistrement et la publication, le ministre fédéral de la Justice a annoncé une réforme du code pénal concernant la prostitution.
Et il y a donc un addendum à la fin du podcast. Allez, c'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Renaud Maes. Bonjour Renaud.
Bonjour.
Renaud, tu es sociologue, professeur à l'Université Saint-Louis et rédac' chef à la Revue Nouvelle, une revue qui propose des analyses sociopolitiques et socioéconomiques.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter et présenter tes travaux pour celles et ceux qui ne te connaissent pas ?
Oui, donc l'essentiel a déjà été dit. Donc je suis sociologue. En fait, à la base, j'ai fait un diplôme en sciences du travail, qui est devenu une branche de la sociologie.
Donc je suis chercheur en sciences sociales. Et puis j'ai un peu roulé ma bosse un peu à droite, à gauche,
ce qui m'a permis de faire beaucoup de travaux de recherche appliqués sur, ben des questions qui vont de la prostitution au porno, au travail du corps, voilà.
Puis j'ai fait des travaux plus sérieux, hein, parce que dans le monde académique, les questions de sexualité ou de travail du corps ne sont pas toujours très bien considérées, sur
des travaux sur l'éducation, l'action sociale dans les universités, ce genre de questions-là, voilà.
Et là aujourd'hui, je pense qu'on est surtout là pour parler de travaux qui sont faits, des travaux que j'ai commencés en 2010 et qui continuent encore maintenant sur les questions de prostitution.
Oui. Alors, avant de se lancer, de plonger au cœur du sujet, je vais te poser la question, mais qu'est-ce qui t'a attiré, qu'est-ce qui t'a amené vers justement ces sujets-là, les questions autour de la prostitution ?
Mais en fait,
c'est venu progressivement. C'est-à-dire que pendant que je faisais ma thèse qui traitait de l'action sociale des universités,
j'ai eu, d'abord, j'ai eu pour ma formation doctorale, alors, c'est vraiment une petite anecdote, hein, mais j'ai eu un exercice qui m'a été donné, qui était : faut que tu fasses un terrain.
Et donc j'ai fait un terrain sur des squats.
Mh.
Et en fait, c'était super. C'était vraiment une super expérience. Je me suis beaucoup amusé. Le but, c'était de voir comment se structuraient les rapports de force à l'intérieur des squats entre différents types de groupes.
Et c'est là en fait où, pour la première fois, j'ai été confronté au fait qu'une série de personnes qui étaient là, qui étaient dans les groupes les plus précaires au sein des squats, pour survivre, en fait, se prostituaient.
Et donc c'est quelque chose qui m'a interpellé, que j'ai essayé d'un peu analyser, mais dans le cadre de cet exercice, c'était très limité.
Et puis, en fait, y a une série d'éléments dans leur discours qui se sont retrouvés quand j'ai commencé à travailler sur l'action sociale des universités, dans le discours de certains étudiants, qui...
En fait, j'ai suivi des cohortes d'étudiants très précaires, vraiment hyper, hyper précaires et des étudiants extrêmement riches pour voir s'ils vivaient la même réalité sociale de l'université.
Et la réponse, évidemment, non. Y a une étanchéité complète entre ces deux mondes. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que dans les étudiants les plus précaires, j'ai vraiment retrouvé en fait les mêmes
discours, les mêmes éléments de langage, sans évoquer vraiment le fait qu'ils se prostituaient, mais
ces éléments, je les connaissais de mon expérience du squat où là, les personnes avaient dit qu'elles se prostituaient.
Donc, je me suis inquiété de : tiens, dans le fond, est-ce qu'il y a pas là un phénomène ? Est-ce que la prostitution étudiante, c'est pas finalement quelque chose qu'on peut effectivement aller trouver ? Et donc,
en fait, là, j'ai commencé à travailler sur la prostitution étudiante et très rapidement, en travaillant sur la prostitution étudiante, je me suis rendu compte qu'il fallait que je l'inscrive dans le cadre général
de l'ensemble des formes de prostitution.
Et donc je me suis intéressé de plus en plus à différentes formes de prostitution. Et en fait, c'est un travail infini parce qu'il y a énormément de formes de prostitution.
Tu dis que, au sein de ces étudiants, étudiantes précaires, tu retrouvais certains éléments de langage, un certain type de discours.
Tu penses à quoi en disant ça ?
Ben, c'est l'évocation de toute une série de termes. Alors, c'est vraiment des termes clés par rapport au fait que ils,
ils arrivaient à subvenir à leurs besoins, les mêmes s'offrir des extras alors qu'ils n'avaient aucune source de moyens, théoriquement.
Mh.
Et donc pour le justifier, c'était : oui, mais bon, j'ai un oncle ou, oui, je suis parti en voyage et j'ai fait une super affaire.
Et en fait, c'est exactement les mêmes éléments de langage qui sont utilisés par les personnes qui se prostituent un peu partout quand elles veulent pas dire qu'elles se prostituent.
Mh.
Alors dans le squat, j'avais l'avantage de savoir qu'elles se prostituaient parce qu'à un moment, elles avaient fini par me le dire.
Les étudiants, c'était beaucoup plus difficile qu'ils le disent. Et ça a vraiment pris du temps. En fait, quand j'ai commencé à travailler sur la prostitution étudiante,
ça a vraiment pris du temps pour que je réussisse à recruter mes quinze premiers témoins qui sont après devenus vingt-cinq.
Et puis, en total, sur l'ensemble de mes travaux, j'ai eu plus d'une cinquantaine de témoins. Ce qui est énorme en fait pour une enquête qualitative.
Alors on va, comme je le disais, plonger au cœur du sujet. Les personnes qui se prostituent, qui sont-elles ?
Quels sont les profils de ces personnes ? Est-ce qu'il y a des généralités, des patterns qu'on retrouve ?
Ce qui est très important déjà de pointer, c'est qu'en fait, il n'existe pas une forme de prostitution. Il y a plein de formes de prostitution et donc
toutes ces formes de prostitution différentes correspondent aussi à des profils sociologiques différents.
Donc si on prend l'escorting de très haut niveau avec les escortes internationales, qui ont des tarifs de, oui, deux mille euros la journée plus la soirée, ce genre de choses,
généralement, ce sont des personnes qui viennent de milieux qui sont pas spécialement défavorisés.
C'est plutôt des personnes éduquées parce que c'est des personnes qui servent aussi de faire-valoir à des gens issus d'un milieu, enfin d'une forme d'élite.
Souvent des personnes qui peuvent être des influenceurs, influenceuses Instagram, etc. Aujourd'hui, donc, ça, c'est vraiment un profil qui va être très spécifique.
Si on regarde la prostitution de rue à Bruxelles, là, on est clairement sur des profils plutôt de personnes qui sont soit en situation illégale, soit,
qu'on a rendues illégales, soit qui sont vraiment dans des situations compliquées d'un point de vue social, souvent venant soit des pays de l'Est, soit, pour une série d'entre elles,
oui, y a un peu l'Espagne, un peu l'Italie, ça reste un peu.
Puis énormément, énormément, Europe centrale, Europe de l'Est. En fait, il y a plein de patterns différents en fonction de toutes les formes de prostitution, ce qui fait que c'est très difficile de faire des grandes généralités.
Il y a un truc qui est clair par contre, c'est qu'il y a une part majoritaire de femmes, déjà, qui se prostituent. Donc ça, on le sait.
Après, si on prend Bruxelles, certains rapports d'organes officiels font état de jusqu'à un tiers d'hommes.
C'est beaucoup, ça.
Oui. Donc les hommes sont pas une portion négligeable non plus. Ça, je pense qu'il faut le pointer. Il faut rajouter à ça le fait, 'fin il y a une petite nuance, c'est que souvent, les organes officiels distinguent deux genres.
Il y a les hommes, il y a les femmes. Mais tout ce qui est un peu gender fluid ou tout ce qui est personnes transgenres est mis dans un paquet, soit homme, soit femme.
Et donc, si on regarde de manière plus fine, en fait, souvent, les personnes transgenres sont assimilées au paquet homme.
Donc en fait, c'est un peu moins d'hommes. Et il y a toutes les personnes transgenres, qui sont pas une portion négligeable non plus. Mais donc,
on sait quand même qu'il y a une majorité de femmes. On sait aussi que dans la très grande majorité des cas,
peu importe la forme de prostitution, la première cause d'entrée en prostitution, c'est un problème de cash flow, une urgence financière.
Ça, c'est quand même un motif qui revient quasi tout le temps. Et donc souvent, c'est des personnes qui, à un moment dans leur parcours, se retrouvent dans une situation de précarité, précarité importante, avec des,
des obligations de remboursement très, très, très, très pressantes.
Et donc ça, c'est quand même un élément. Ce qui veut dire évidemment qu'on a quand même une majorité aussi de personnes qui sont,
ben, à la base issues de milieux populaires, qui sont plus faiblement scolarisées et qui ont vraiment des problèmes financiers.
Donc voilà. Mais comme j'ai dit, si on regarde les top escort, ça va plus du tout être ce profil-là, forcément.
Ouais, ouais. Donc si on reprend ce profil de femmes qui se prostituent pour répondre à un besoin important, une urgence financière, est-ce que la prostitution est assumée ?
Est-ce que c'est un choix revendiqué ou bien est-ce que ça va être quelque chose qu'on va essayer de cacher, de dire c'est juste une solution temporaire ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'on a des femmes qui vont assumer ça comme étant leur métier ?
Ce qu'il faut bien voir, c'est que, comme il y a plein de formes de prostitution, il y a plein de manières de s'identifier à l'activité prostitutionnelle.
Et donc, il y a des personnes qui vont d'emblée, lorsqu'elles franchissent le pas de se prostituer, considérer que, à partir de maintenant, c'est mon travail et je le revendique.
Il y a toute une série de personnes qui rentrent dans ce cas-là, qui sont extrêmement minoritaires à l'échelle de l'ensemble des personnes qui se prostituent, mais elles existent et,
souvent, elles sont assez visibles parce que ce sont des personnes qui tout de suite sont dans une démarche plus militante aussi, souvent.
On peut les voir dans les médias, par exemple.
Oui oui, tout à fait. Mais c'est pas le seul profil qu'on voit dans les médias. Le deuxième profil aussi, c'est les personnes qui, progressivement, au fur et à mesure de l'exercice de l'activité, développent une militance,
là, peut-être plus dans une approche syndicale, c'est-à-dire dans une approche de : on crée un collectif pour défendre nos droits à l'intérieur d'une activité.
Avec évidemment la question de savoir est-ce que c'est un travail, est-ce que c'est pas un travail. Enfin, je suppose que ça, on peut revenir tout à l'heure.
Et puis après, il y a effectivement, ben toute une série de personnes qui vont toujours le vivre comme étant une activité un peu honteuse, un peu problématique.
Et une grande majorité des personnes qui se prostituent vont plutôt avoir tendance à cloisonner, à faire en sorte que le moins possible de personnes sachent qu'elles se prostituent, à mener une double vie.
Et donc voilà. De nouveau, c'est difficile de faire un portrait très général parce que toutes les situations existent.
Mais c'est vrai que de manière statistique, si on regarde le gros des cohortes, les personnes qui se prostituent ont plutôt tendance à toujours dire que même si c'est devenu un truc qu'elles font depuis des années,
la première réponse, c'est oui, mais enfin, c'est toujours temporaire.
L'enquêteur qui leur pose la question aura d'emblée cette réponse-là. Oui, c'est temporaire le temps que. Et la deuxième chose, c'est effectivement, on se rend très vite compte que pas mal de personnes prostituées essayent de effectivement
complètement cacher l'information à leurs enfants, à leur, éventuellement leur conjoint,
à leur cercle familial, à leur cercle social.
Et donc ça, c'est quand même un leitmotiv assez fréquent.
Oui, tu donnes l'exemple des prostituées étudiantes qui, voilà, essaient de le cacher ou on pouvait éventuellement le deviner, mais c'était pas assumé quoi.
Mais dans le cas des prostituées étudiantes, il y a aussi un truc très spécifique hein, qu'on a vraiment mis en évidence dans, enfin que j'ai mis en évidence dans mes travaux, mais qui revient aussi
dans les travaux de collègues, notamment
Marie Bruninx à Mons, a fait une chouette étude très psy, mais super intéressante sur des étudiantes qui se prostituaient à Mons.
Et en fait, il y a quand même un truc qui revient, c'est vraiment le cloisonnement de l'activité quoi. L'angoisse que ça se sache sur le campus, ça se sache dans l'institution d'enseignement.
Et ça, c'est vraiment une problématique spécifique aux étudiantes. Elles ont peur que si ça se sait sur le campus, ça va être, un, elles vont être source de moqueries pour les autres.
Deux, ça risque de nuire à leur réussite et elles risquent d'avoir le mépris des professeurs ou d'être plus spécialement harcelées par certains profs libidineux.
Enfin, voilà, il y a vraiment cette angoisse que ça percole sur le campus. Ça, c'est vraiment très spécifique aux étudiantes.
Mh. Oui, c'est à mettre en lien avec toute la culture étudiante, les cercles, les baptêmes, etc.
Tout à fait. Oui, il y a la culture étudiante avec le folklore, avec toutes ses représentations hyper sexistes et hyper violentes de la femme.
Et puis il y a quand même aussi le patrimoine machiste de l'institution elle-même. C'est-à-dire, il faut quand même rappeler qu'on a eu deux recteurs, rectrices, en Communauté française depuis, enfin
en Belgique francophone, depuis le XIXe siècle.
Enfin, donc là, on a quand même la démonstration que l'unif reste quand même très centrée sur les hommes. Et puis dans--
quand on regarde qui écrit aujourd'hui les cartes blanches qui remettent en question le féminisme qu'on qualifie à tort de néo-féminisme, c'est quand même souvent aussi des hommes professeurs d'université.
Donc, je veux dire, les revendications féministes sont pas forcément si bienvenues dans les institutions. Alors, il y a une évolution.
Dès qu'elles font un micro-progrès, elles le surmédiatisent, mais en réalité, il reste un cœur bien ancré de machisme au sein des institutions universitaires.
Oui, j'ai quelques idées de profils qui correspondent à ce que tu viens de décrire, mais on ne donnera pas de nom.
Mais donc voilà, cette idée de moquerie, de honte, voilà, de, on pointe du doigt et c'est absolument pas ou très peu accepté l'idée de se prostituer.
Ces constructions, ces institutions-là, d'où est-ce qu'elles viennent ? Et comment est-ce qu'on explique que le fait de se prostituer soit autant stigmatisé dans nos sociétés ?
Mais alors, en fait, on peut vraiment faire un retour en arrière très lointain. Je veux dire, de tout temps, la personne prostituée en Occident a une connotation plutôt négative, en tout cas depuis l'époque romaine.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que nos représentations actuelles sont quand même fort le produit du XIXe siècle et de la révolution industrielle.
Et il y a vraiment trois figures de la personne prostituée qui s'imposent au XIXe. La première figure, c'est la putain vénérienne.
Alors la putain vénérienne, c'est vraiment un souci de santé publique. Donc au XIXe siècle, enfin au XVIIIe et puis au XIXe siècle, on commence à se préoccuper très fort de la propagation des maladies dans les villes.
Comment est-ce qu'on peut la régler ? Et on a toute une série de médecins hygiénistes, Parent-Duchâtelet, par exemple,
qui est vraiment super connu parce que c'est, en fait, c'est les premières études à grande échelle sur l'activité prostitutionnelle,
avec des recensements systématiques.
C'est aussi, en fait, c'est augure de la sociologie
moderne et contemporaine. Et ben ces médecins hygiénistes, ils vont essayer de réguler l'activité prostitutionnelle pour réguler la propagation des maladies d'une manière générale et en particulier des maladies vénériennes.
Donc ça, c'est la première préoccupation, c'est la putain vénérienne. Elle pose problème parce qu'elle propage les maladies.
Donc forcément, on ne l'aime pas et elle est vraiment très problématique. La deuxième figure qui s'impose assez naturellement quand on parle de personnes prostituées, c'est la putain délinquante.
Alors ça, encore aujourd'hui hein, c'est vraiment un truc qui revient de manière très, très récurrente.
C'est l'idée que les personnes prostituées, par le milieu dans lequel elles sont, le milieu prostitutionnel, sont amenées à commettre tout le temps des petits larcins, etc.
Et donc ces personnes sont fondamentalement dangereuses parce qu'on ne peut jamais leur faire confiance. D'ailleurs, elles mentent tout le temps.
Et d'ailleurs il suffit qu'on laisse un peu traîner d'argent et elles vont vite le prendre, s'en saisir.
Et donc, il y a cette idée de la putain rusée, manipulatrice qui en fait, en plus, commet tout le temps plein de petits larcins avec une idée de dégénérescence progressive.
Donc, il y a vraiment cette image de la putain dégénérée. Et puis il y a la troisième image qui est aussi, qui s'impose, qui en fait prolonge celle de la putain délinquante, qui est vraiment la putain débile.
C'est-à-dire la personne prostituée aurait finalement une prédisposition à être particulièrement idiote, à n'être qu'un corps.
Elle est frigide, nous dit par exemple Pauline Tarnowski dans un bouquin hyper célèbre sur la prostitution au XIXe siècle.
Et c'est quelque chose qui va revenir, hein, souvent, cette idée que finalement,
y a une forme de, ouais, de dégénérescence profonde des personnes qui font ça, éventuellement parce qu'elles sont prédisposées, hein, donc y a aussi-
C'est pas du tout une idée génétique.
Ah oui oui,
évidemment. Et alors derrière ça, y a aussi, et ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on va retrouver par exemple dans la littérature au début du XXe siècle, cette idée que finalement, la putain est l'expression,
de la féminité lorsqu'on ne lui met pas de règles et qu'on ne la cadre pas comme il faut.
Et donc il faut bien la cadrer pour éviter qu'elle, naturellement, la femme a tendance à être une putain. Donc voilà.
Mais donc c'est vraiment, en fait, ces trois figures, c'est vraiment trois figures repoussoirs qui sont construites, qu'on va retrouver dans la littérature, dans la littérature scientifique, qu'on va retrouver encore aujourd'hui, hein.
C'est fascinant. Par exemple, quand on parle de prévention contre le sida, la manière dont on considère les personnes prostituées, parfois, on a des relents, en fait, de l'hygiénisme du XIXe, quoi.
On revient à cette idée de la putain vénérienne contagieuse, dangereuse, dont il faut se méfier.
Et, encore récemment, je lisais les travaux d'une collègue américaine sur la question de, ben voilà, modification des cognitions, des capacités cognitives des personnes prostituées.
Et on a, notamment aux États-Unis, mais pas que, toute une série de travaux qui restent dans l'idée que les personnes qui se prostituent
sont à la base traumatisées par quelque chose qui est de l'ordre soit d'un accident génétique, soit d'un accident personnel, que ça modifie leur cerveau et que parce qu'elles sont modifiées et donc pas en,
au total des capacités humaines, elles sont un peu abîmées, eh ben c'est naturellement un engrenage vers la prostitution.
Et donc on garde cette idée de la putain dégénérée qui est absolument effroyable. Et ça s'impose très naturellement parce que ça fait partie de nos représentations collectives.
Ouais, ouais. Donc tu disais trois piliers, voilà, bien installés déjà au XIXe siècle, mais encore aujourd'hui dans les dépictions qu'on voit au cinéma, dans la littérature, etc.
Ça reste encore très présent.
Et cette idée que finalement, la prostitution, c'est l'état naturel de la femme si on ne l'encadre pas, on peut le retrouver dans le discours de certains cinéastes aujourd'hui.
'Fin, je me souviens des commentaires autour de la sortie de Jeune et jolie. C'était fascinant, les discours de critiques et les discours du réalisateur.
C'était ça. On était dans ce même vieux discours. Et donc oui, je pense qu'il y a vraiment une prégnance importante de ces représentations-là, quoi.
Ouais, ouais. Alors, si on revient maintenant à notre petite Belgique,
donc on a parlé de, voilà, des situations qui vont amener à la prostitution, le rapport, comment c'était perçu par la société.
J'aimerais maintenant qu'on parle de comment c'est perçu par la loi. Que dit le code pénal en Belgique au sujet de la prostitution ?
Alors, on a le code pénal le plus hypocrite au monde ou à peu près, puisqu'en gros, il n'est pas interdit de se prostituer, mais tout ce qui entoure l'activité est en fait interdit. Et donc
il est interdit de faire la publicité de la prostitution. En fait, il est interdit de faire de la publicité de la débauche, il est interdit d'inciter à la débauche, il est interdit de tirer profit
de la débauche d'autrui, il est interdit, évidemment, bon il y a aussi la législation spécifique sur les mineurs qui est beaucoup plus stricte.
Là, il est interdit, la prostitution des mineurs est interdite, purement et simplement. Mais c'est vrai qu'en fait, globalement, notre code pénal organise les choses comme suit : une personne peut décider de se prostituer,
alors décider ou contrainte ou choix ou etc.
Ça, c'est quelque chose dont on peut parler après. Mais donc voilà, elle se retrouve dans une situation où elle se dit : « Ben voilà, je vais me prostituer.
» Elle peut juste s'asseoir sur une chaise et attendre que les choses se passent. Elle n'a pas la latitude d'aller démarcher pour trouver les clients.
Donc ça, c'est ce que le code pénal prévoit. Évidemment, en pratique,
en pratique, ben il suffit d'ouvrir un Vlan
pour les plus anciens, d'ouvrir une application de rencontre pour les plus jeunes et on a des annonces de personnes prostituées, on en a plein et jamais le parquet va faire des poursuites sur un truc pareil.
Donc en fait, ce qui est fascinant, c'est qu'en plus, on a un code pénal qui n'est même plus appliqué-
Mmh.
Par les autorités judiciaires du pays. Et c'est très logique, parce que sinon, elles n'auraient pas fini, l'encombrement judiciaire serait-
OK, donc-
Absolument hallucinant.
Donc c'est ça l'explication. C'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne poursuit pas les personnes qui se prostituent, les personnes qui tirent ou en tout cas qui tirent profit de la prostitution.
Ça, on les poursuit. Ça, on les poursuit.
OK.
On peut poursuivre les personnes qui tirent profit, mais généralement, en fait, on n'est plus aussi strict que ce que prévoit vraiment le cadre juridique.
C'est-à-dire, on va vraiment chercher les vrais proxénètes-
Les réseaux de prostitution, les maisons closes, ce genre de choses.
Mais c'est vrai que nos textes de loi sont vraiment extrêmement restrictifs, quoi. Donc normalement, Vlan pourraient être condamnés pour avoir publié, ben, de l'incitation à la débauche.
Et ils ne le sont pas.
Ils ne le sont pas.
Parce que sinon, ce serait, il y aurait trop de choses à gérer, trop de dossiers qui s'empileraient.
Ce serait, ce serait, déjà, ce serait très très mal vu en termes de liberté de la presse.
Ouais, ouais.
Et puis, 'fin, ça ouvre plein de questions. Et en fait, le parquet ne considère pas que ce soit une priorité.
Mmh.
Parce que c'est vrai que par rapport aux situations prostitutionnelles, ce qui pose quand même le plus une difficulté, c'est quand même, ben l'existence de réseaux de traite. Ça, c'est un vrai grand souci.
Et finalement, poursuivre la prostituée qui a fait publier une annonce dans Le Blanc, c'est très dérisoire par rapport à la poursuite de proxénètes organisés quoi. Ça, c'est évident.
Donc ça, c'est le code pénal au niveau fédéral, la Belgique. Ensuite, il me semble qu'il y a d'autres règlements à d'autres niveaux.
Ah oui, mais ça, c'est la Belgique, c'est ça qui est formidable.
La lasagne institutionnelle est encore là.
Ah oui oui, mais alors là, elle est particulièrement kafkaïenne parce qu'en plus, il y a des morceaux de niveaux qui rentrent les uns dans les autres et tout hein.
C'est vraiment tout à fait fascinant. Donc on a des petits éléments de législation qui arrivent çà et là des régions.
Généralement, c'est plus sous forme de conseils donnés aux entités en dessous, mais il y a un petit peu. Il y a des préoccupations au niveau de la Communauté française, par exemple sur des thématiques spécifiques, l'accès à la santé, etc.
Bon maintenant, la santé, plus vraiment au niveau de la Fédération, mais bon pendant tout un temps, ça y était, donc il y avait des éléments là.
Et puis après, il y a le niveau des provinces. Bon ça, on va simplifier, on va pas en parler, c'est difficile.
Il y a surtout les communes. Et les communes et les zones de police qui ne sont pas la même chose, comme on le sait.
Et là, il y a des choses absolument dingues parce que d'une commune à l'autre, on va considérer la question de la prostitution de manière complètement différente.
Et donc on a des communes qui vont prendre des réglementations dans le cadre des sanctions administratives communales, qui vont tout faire pour interdire la prostitution, et le fait de racoler le client.
Mais bon, la définition de racolage devient vite simplement être là à attendre, c'est déjà du racolage parce que c'est du racolage passif.
Donc, on arrive vite à des trucs très délirants.
Il y a des communes qui vont, au contraire essayer d'utiliser leurs moyens pour,
encadrer, légiférer pour que finalement, on soit dans un cadre qui est presque réglementariste, alors qu'officiellement, au niveau fédéral, on est toujours dans l'abolitionnisme.
Donc là, il y a aussi des trucs qui deviennent un peu absurdes où une petite commune à un endroit dit : « Ben là, oui, c'est bien, OK, on va avoir N bars où les personnes pourront se prostituer.
Pas en dehors, parce que comme ça, c'est bien contenu. On gère juste les plaintes d'un petit quartier, des habitants autour d'un petit quartier, c'est bien.
Alors, on fait des médiations, tout ça. Et puis, mais alors en dehors hein, c'est fini. Fini, fini. » Et puis on a des trucs,
qui deviennent complètement aberrants parce qu'évidemment, au sein d'une zone de police, il y a parfois plusieurs communes, c'est le cas à Bruxelles.
Et donc d'une rue à l'autre, les mêmes policiers doivent savoir que dans un cas, il faut considérer que la personne qui va se prostituer, c'est tout à fait inacceptable,
mais que juste, on passe au coin de la rue et là, en fait, c'est complètement différent.
La personne a le droit d'être là, en tout cas, on tolère son existence. Et donc on est dans des trucs, only in Belgium quoi. C'est-
T'as quelques exemples de, voilà, de communes qui se font particulièrement remarquer parce que voilà, elles essayent de complètement réglementer le truc ou d'autres qui-
Deux communes limitrophes qui ont des politiques complètement différentes, c'est Schaerbeek et Bruxelles.
OK.
Alors, il y a un autre exemple. Bon, il y a la zone de police Bruxelles-Ixelles. Ixelles, en fait, a une tendance jusque-là hein, jusqu'à présent, c'est en train un peu de bouger, mais a plutôt toléré la prostitution sur son territoire.
Bruxelles, plus du tout. Et donc, il y a une artère de prostitution bien connue à Bruxelles qui est l'avenue Louise.
L'avenue Louise, en fait, elle est sur le territoire de Bruxelles-Ville, mais elle traverse Ixelles.
Et donc, en fait, les personnes prostituées ne peuvent pas être sur les trottoirs de l'avenue Louise, mais il suffit qu'elles se mettent légèrement un peu plus loin dans une rue qui est sur le territoire d'Ixelles et c'est bon.
Mais c'est absurde, évidemment. Là, on est dans du délire complet quoi. Et personne semble se préoccuper. Alors en plus, il y a quand même une politique aussi très réactive de certains bourgmestres qui vont avoir...
Il y a des personnes qui se plaignent parce qu'il y a une personne prostituée au coin de leur immeuble, ils trouvent que ça dégrade l'ambiance, c'est dangereux, enfin voilà.
Et alors, on envoie vite les policiers pour dire : « Ah ben, il faut vous déplacer, madame. » Et puis elle se déplace sur un autre quartier.
Et puis, en fait, quelques jours plus tard, ben une autre personne va se plaindre. Et puis, en fait, les personnes prostituées se déplacent comme ça.
Il y a une espèce de migration organisée de zone en zone au sein d'une même commune. Et c'est des trucs qui sont pas du tout réfléchis, où il y a aucune coordination, aucune intelligence.
C'est intéressant parce que tu donnes l'exemple de Bruxelles-Ville où tu disais : « C'est complètement interdit. »
Mh.
Mais donc l'avenue Louise, ça reste l'artère de prostitution principale à Bruxelles.
C'est une des grosses artères de prostitution. C'est là qu'on trouve la prostitution de rue, mais de niveau supérieur.
C'est-à-dire, avec des personnes qui sont généralement plutôt en résidence légale sur le territoire et qui sont plutôt en forme, qui sont plus jeunes.
Autour du quartier Ixelles, maintenant, il y a quasi plus de prostitution visible en rue. Très très peu, en tout cas, pour le moment.
Mais là, on a un autre type de public. On a les personnes qui sont dans des situations sociales nettement plus précaires, avec souvent des problèmes d'addiction qui sont quand même très sérieux-
Mh
...et qui sont généralement pas en ordre de séjour. Enfin, non. Une part non négligeable, en tout cas, alors, je sais pas dire exactement combien, mais c'est près de la moitié, quelque chose comme ça,
n'ont pas de titre de séjour parfaitement dans les règles.
Et qu'est-ce qui va expliquer alors politiquement le fait qu'un bourgmestre va avoir une approche plutôt abolitionniste de la prostitution alors qu'un autre va trouver ça OK, va essayer de réglementer la question ?
Mais donc, je pense qu'il y a deux grands facteurs. Le premier grand facteur, c'est une question d'abord de conviction personnelle.
Je pense, voilà. Tout simplement, il y a des gens qui considèrent que de leur point de vue moral, la prostitution ne pose pas de problème.
D'autres, ils considèrent que c'est complètement amoral. Mais je pense que ce facteur-là est en fait souvent le second, voire le troisième, voire le tout dernier, très très loin.
D'accord. C'est celui qu'on va mettre en avant, mais c'est pas forcément celui qui va justifier le fait d'écrire un texte de loi.
Ce qui est généralement le déterminant, c'est comment est-ce que j'envisage de gérer le quartier et quel projet que j'ai pour le quartier.
Ça, c'est toujours le gros enjeu. Et clairement, aujourd'hui, sur Bruxelles, on voit qu'y a une volonté claire de gentrifier une série de quartiers.
Ixelles, c'est le meilleur exemple. Le but, c'est vraiment d'aller vers un quartier avec des revenus moyens et supérieurs, favorisant aussi au maximum un tourisme massif dans le centre-ville.
Je pense qu'il y a vraiment une volonté quand même importante à Bruxelles de continuer à développer le tourisme comme une grosse source commerciale.
C'est une politique régionale, mais c'est aussi une politique très forte au niveau de Bruxelles-Ville.
Ce qui est intéressant à ce niveau-là, c'est que, évidemment, ben les revenus moyens et revenus plus supérieurs qui vont arriver dans le quartier, ils aiment pas trop qu'il y ait des personnes prostituées au pied de leur immeuble.
Alors soit parce que
on associe ça à des nuisances. Le comité de quartier, qui est très actif sur le quartier Alain-Braille, Ixelles, dit souvent : « Oui, les personnes prostituées respectent pas le potager collectif, elles écrasent leur mégot dans les légumes.
» 'Fin, c'est le genre d'exemples qu'elles reprennent. Mais y a aussi une considération très pragmatique qui est simplement dans les quartiers de prostitution, généralement, parce qu'on a l'image de risque de délinquance, etc.,
ben les biens immobiliers perdent leur valeur.
Donc, ils ont un intérêt aussi financier, mine de rien, à évacuer les personnes prostituées le plus possible des rues, en tout cas les rendre les plus invisibles possible, parce que ça maximise la valeur de leurs biens.
Et donc c'est clair que dans le cas d'une politique de gentrification, on a tendance à pousser les prostituées le plus possible à l'intérieur, le plus loin possible dans les recoins et plus leur laisser d'espace pour être visibles.
Et je pense que, donc ça, c'est vraiment le cœur, hein, la motivation profonde de ce type de politique. Et puis derrière, évidemment, c'est très difficile à assumer quoi, parce que politiquement, ça pose quand même question.
Envoyer les personnes sans autre forme de procès dans les recoins les plus sombres. Et donc on légitime après par un discours moral, en puisant dans un corpus idéologique.
Donc voilà. Mais clairement, hein, les trois préoccupations majeures des bourgmestres, c'est : un, les nuisances sur le voisinage.
Deux, combien de ménages qui payent des impôts, je peux faire rentrer dans les quartiers ? Parce que plus y aura de personnes qui payent l'additionnel et l'IPP, plus je crée d'argent dans ma commune.
Et trois : est-ce que éventuellement, y a pas moyen aussi de profiter un peu de la manne d'argent qui remonte de la prostitution ?
Voilà. Et ça, c'est un peu un choix quoi. Soit on gentrifie et alors du coup, on diminue la... Soit, en fait, finalement, on encadre la prostitution pour aller un peu pomper de l'argent généré par l'activité prostitutionnelle.
Toujours sur la question de Bruxelles-Ville spécifiquement, on avait parlé donc d'un arrêté qui avait été donné pendant la pandémie, pendant le-
Mh
...confinement, où là, justement, on disait explicitement : « Les prostituées ne peuvent plus faire de racolage sur la voie publique-
Non
...parce que voilà, y a un risque de propager le virus. » Et donc c'est, c'est encore une fois, c'est ça qui m'étonne, c'est qu'on parle de Bruxelles-Ville comme un exemple de commune où c'est absolument interdit.
Et puis on se rend compte que pendant la pandémie, c'est encore plus interdit. Et là, on va déployer des moyens pour-
Y a une volonté claire. 'Fin, après, chaque fois que je dis ça, je sais qu'y a des attachés de cabinet qui me tombent dessus en me disant : « Oui, c'est un procès d'intention », mais 'fin, à un moment, il faut arrêter de rire.
Y a une volonté claire qu'il n'y ait plus de prostitution de rue dans le quartier de l'Alain-Braille. Tous les moyens sont bons.
Là, y a eu la pandémie, donc c'était particulièrement pratique. Mais à un moment, faut arrêter de rire.
Les personnes qui se prostituent dans le quartier Ixelles, ça fait super longtemps qu'elles souffrent vraiment de contrôles systématiques par la police.
Et ça, c'est organisé par des injonctions du bourgmestre, qui sont par ailleurs validées par le collège de la zone. Donc, c'est pas non plus juste le bourgmestre tout seul.
Donc à un moment, il faut arrêter de rire. Je pense qu'y a vraiment une volonté parce que c'est potentiellement un quartier où le développement immobilier, touristique, restaurant fancy, tout ça est énorme.
Y a vraiment une volonté de pousser les personnes prostituées loin de ce quartier. Et donc oui,
c'était un énième avatar de cette politique-là et un particulièrement violent parce qu'en fait, y avait aucune solution de rechange qui était ouverte aux personnes prostituées.
Aucune, hein. Et que faut quand même pointer que pour une partie d'entre elles, lorsqu'elles s'adressent au CPAS, on leur dit pas : « Welcome, venez, on va vous aider.
» Une partie d'entre elles, quand elles s'adressent au CPAS, on leur dit : « Bah vous avez pas de papiers, votre titre de séjour tiendra pas la route.
Vous voulez faire la démarche, mais vous allez vous faire expulser, madame. » Et l'autre partie, on lui dit : « Bah vous avez un revenu.
Donc pourquoi on vous aiderait ? » Et donc c'est terrible parce que dans les mêmes communes qui disent : « Ah non hein, la prostitution, c'est vraiment pas un moyen acceptable, machin.
» Alors après, on emballe ça dans des discours : « Oui, parce que c'est dégueulasse pour la cause des femmes, pour les femmes qui le vivent, etc.
» On est abolitionniste soi-disant, sauf qu'on n'est pas du tout abolitionniste, parce que l'abolitionnisme, historiquement
Il se préoccupe vraiment de la personne prostituée, de manière peut-être parfois un peu paternaliste, mais il y a un vrai souci de la personne prostituée.
Donc jamais un abolitionniste, jamais, dira : Ah, le racolage, c'est complètement interdit, on va sanctionner les personnes.
Mieux, l'abolitionnisme, c'est l'abolition de quoi en fait ? C'est l'abolition du fichage des personnes prostituées.
C'est ça que ça désigne. L'abolition, historiquement, c'est un courant qui va demander qu'on arrête de contrôler les personnes prostituées de manière systématique en les fichant et en leur imposant les examens sanitaires.
Alors après, elles veulent aussi l'abolition de la prostitution. Mais l'historique profond de la source du mot abolition, c'est ça.
C'est de dire on abolit en fait le cadre du fichage. Or,
ce que concrètement on fait quand on fait un contrôle policier systématique des personnes prostituées, on revient en fait au bon vieux fichage, qui est justement le truc le moins abolitionniste possible.
Donc, il faut quand même le pointer. Souvent, on entend des grandes déclarations de promesses disant : Mais moi, je suis réglementariste ou moi, je suis abolitionniste.
Mais derrière, en fait, c'est du flan. Il y a juste la volonté de suivre une politique de développement d'un quartier ou d'encadrement, de gestion des nuisances de voisinage, etc.
Mais c'est pas du tout... 'fin, y a pas de vision politique majeure ou de positionnement clair sur la cause des femmes.
On a employé à plusieurs reprises des termes comme réglementarisme, abolitionnisme, prohibition. J'aimerais qu'on prenne juste un instant pour définir un peu ces termes.
Donc, tu viens d'expliquer, voilà, l'abolitionnisme et ce que ça signifie. Si je te parle maintenant du néo-abolitionnisme, c'est quoi la différence ?
Ah oui. Alors, on va reprendre d'abord avec le réglementarisme, si tu permets, parce que ce que va faire le réglementarisme, c'est un peu la première doctrine qui émerge à la fin du dix-huitième siècle
et puis qui va vraiment prendre corps au dix-neuvième.
Et ça vient de médecins hygiénistes, ça vient de gestionnaires de police, ça vient d'urbanistes, ça vient... Et le but, c'est vraiment d'imposer un cadre à la prostitution qui est vue comme une espèce de chose inexorable.
Il y aura toujours des personnes prostituées. Y a cette expression de Parent-Duchâtelet qui est-
Égout séminal.
Voilà, l'égout séminal, qui est quand même vraiment l'expression la moins réjouissante qui soit.
C'est assez glauque, quand même.
Surtout quand on sait qu'à l'époque, les égouts étaient assez ouverts. Donc... Mais il y a vraiment cette idée.
Donc voilà, comment est-ce qu'on peut gérer le truc ? Eh ben, on va contrôler les personnes prostituées, s'assurer qu'elles soient pas trop porteuses de maladies vénériennes.
Donc, on va leur imposer des examens médicaux. On va leur imposer des lieux où elles seront plutôt enfermées pour pas qu'elles soient trop sur la rue.
Surtout que bon, elles sont quand même vite dans les petits larcins, tout ça. Donc, il y a tout ce que j'ai exemplé tout à l'heure.
Et donc, on met un cadre, vraiment un cadre, les maisons closes. On impose des codes, les couleurs des maisons closes.
On impose des protocoles. On va jusque, dans certaines villes, contrôler les tarifs, hein, imposer des tarifs. Voilà.
Alors ça, c'est vraiment le cadre réglementariste. Et puis, fin du dix-neuvième siècle, début du vingtième siècle, il y a tout le mouvement abolitionniste qui s'interroge parce qu'on trouve dans les maisons closes des mineurs.
Alors, il y a beaucoup de travail qui a été fait sur l'affaire de la traite des Blanches, notamment dans les maisons closes bruxelloises.
Et là, il faut lire les travaux de Jean-Michel Chameau, qui sont absolument passionnants. On voit qu'en fait, il y a une grosse partie de ces affaires qui sont un peu des affaires montées en spectacle.
Qu'il y a de la triche, là-derrière et tout ça. Mais il y a tout un courant d'opinion qui est plutôt lié, en fait, historiquement, au protestantisme, aux pays protestants,
mais il y a aussi des catholiques qui vont se raccrocher et qui disent : Mais en fait, ça va pas du tout parce que ces personnes qui se prostituent, c'est des victimes quoi.
C'est des victimes, il faut les protéger. Le système prostitutionnel est extrêmement violent avec elles. Il faut pouvoir les réhabiliter, les réintégrer dans la société en tant que bonnes citoyennes et bons citoyens.
Oui, mais pas en tant que prostituées.
Et donc il faut qu'elles arrêtent de se prostituer. Mais comme elles sont des victimes, là, on va vraiment, en fait, plutôt interdire tout ce qui leur permet de se prostituer, tout ce qui facilite la prostitution.
On va interdire le fichage et on va essayer de les prendre en charge à l'intérieur de dispositifs de charité pour les sortir de la prostitution.
Donc c'est aussi là qu'on va commencer à avoir les programmes de sortie, hein. Alors, les premiers programmes de sortie, c'est, on organise dans un couvent une sortie de la prostitution à coup de
traitement de choc et de récitation de la Bible, hein.
C'est ça les premiers programmes de sortie. Puis ça évolue au fur et à mesure des techniques aussi.
On va faire des électrochocs, etc. Donc, il y a toute la psychiatrisation de la sortie de prostitution qui va prendre énormément, par exemple, en Grande-Bretagne.
Enfin, voilà. Bon, ça, c'est le courant abolitionniste, avec des sensibilités déjà à la base qui sont parfois un peu diverses, hein.
Il y a des abolitionnistes qui vont être très préoccupés de la santé des personnes prostituées, qui vont essayer de développer vraiment des programmes centrés sur la personne prostituée.
Et puis, il y a des abolitionnistes qui vont être beaucoup plus dans le développement des politiques publiques. Il faut absolument que dans les politiques publiques, il y ait des engagements clairs qui soient pris au niveau des lois, etc.
Donc, on a vraiment la branche plus action sociale et puis la branche plus action politique qui sont pas toujours complètement d'accord.
Donc, il y a déjà des nuances. Et puis après, en fait, on a des réactualisations de ces deux grands courants et ces deux courants se réactualisent
dans les pays scandinaves, pour ce qui est le courant abolitionniste, avec l'émergence de ce qu'on a appelé le néo-abolitionnisme.
Et le néo-abolitionnisme, en fait, son idée, c'est plus qu'on interdit tout ce qui permet à la personne de se prostituer.
Son idée, c'est de dire : on va pénaliser tous ceux qui participent à la prostitution et qui ne sont pas des personnes qui se prostituent.
Et donc, on va en particulier pénaliser le client, le considérer comme coupable d'un crime. Alors, il y a un truc qui est très important à noter,
c'est que ce crime est généralement, pour la plupart des néo-abolitionnistes scandinaves, pas un crime contre la personne qui se prostitue.
C'est-à-dire, on considère pas que le client est le méchant dominant de la personne qui se prostitue. On considère qu'il fait un crime contre l'État.
Contre l'ordre public, ouais.
Contre l'ordre public, dans lequel, en fait, on consacre l'égalité des hommes et des femmes.
C'est aussi une vision où, essentiellement, on considère que la prostitution est un problème homme-femme et on néglige quand même assez fort la dimension prostitution masculine, par exemple.
Et donc ça, c'est vraiment la mouvance néo-abolitionniste.
Et elle naît en grande partie en Suède parce que c'est vraiment là que les débats sont les plus chauds, mais elle existe aussi en Finlande, elle existe de la même manière en Norvège.
Mais elle naît en Suède d'un compromis, en fait, entre les mouvances social-démocrates progressistes et les mouvances plus conservatrices chrétiennes de femmes.
Alors, les social-démocrates, ce sont celles qui vont développer le volet action sociale du néo-abolitionnisme. C'est elles qui vont mettre en place les refuges, notamment.
Et c'est elles qui vont accepter l'idée que oui, effectivement, on peut condamner le client comme un compromis qui est, mais du coup, on touche vraiment pas à la personne prostituée et on s'assure qu'elle puisse absolument avoir un refuge
et que toute personne prostituée
que l'on retrouve, puisse être envoyée dans un refuge et qu'on puisse l'aider à
à avoir une carrière.
Mais là, on n'est plus dans le, on va la redresser. Là, on est carrément, on va lui offrir des possibilités d'avoir une véritable carrière
professionnelle, quitte à investir dans ses études, quitte à financer de manière massive tout un accompagnement social.
Et donc, on est vraiment dans un travail social hyper poussé quoi. On est vraiment dans autre chose quoi. Il s'agit plus de redresser la personne.
Mh.
Il s'agit vraiment de lui ouvrir plein d'opportunités.
Donc ça, c'est le néo-abolitionnisme.
Ouais.
C'est quoi les points faibles de cette approche-là ?
Alors, le point faible du néo-abolitionnisme, il est évident. C'est qu'en fait, lorsqu'on pénalise les clients, le risque pris par les clients, du coup, se reporte directement sur les personnes prostituées.
Et donc c'est le gros problème dans les rapports prostitutionnels. C'est qu'en fait, comme il y a moins de clients, que ceux-ci prennent plus de risques.
Bon, ça, c'est le premier point faible hein, le plus évident. C'est qu'en fait, du coup,
les clients disent : Ah ben, je prends plein de risques, mais du coup, tu me fais un tarif hein, parce que si jamais je me fais choper par les flics, ben, je vais devoir payer vachement, donc t'assumes, tu réduis le tarif.
Ça amène aussi à aller dans des lieux qui sont beaucoup moins visibles, puisque le client prend un risque. Et donc ça mène à potentiellement plus de risques pour la personne prostituée, en ce compris des risques physiques.
Ça, c'est le premier point faible. Deuxième point faible, c'est que le compromis qui a été fait entre les socio-démocrates et les franges plus conservatrices a pas tenu très très longtemps. Et très rapidement,
en fait, il y a toute une série de personnes prostituées qui sont passées du statut de : Oh, les pauvres victimes, on va les aider, on va leur ouvrir toutes les chances,
à finalement : Vous, vous êtes quand même des personnes immorales et on veut pas de vous sur le territoire.
Et donc, en gros, la Suède, par exemple, elle expulse massivement toute personne qui est étrangère et qui se prostitue et qui ne veut pas se reconnaître comme victime de traite.
Déjà parce que peut-être, elle n'est pas victime de traite. Et donc, à partir de là, ben hop, c'est : Ah ben, se prostituer, c'est pas acceptable comme moyen de gagner sa vie.
Donc, vous êtes expulsé du territoire sans autre forme de procès. Là, on n'est plus dans l'action sociale, émancipation, tout ça.
On est dans un truc qui est une sanction hyper violente. Troisième point faible de l'approche néo-abolitionniste, c'est qu'en plus, elle est locale.
Et alors, si vous allez en Suède, il y a un truc très très drôle, que vous vous intéressez à la prostitution un petit peu.
Donc moi, je me suis baladé pas mal à Stockholm à ce niveau-là, c'est qu'on vous propose des croisières pour profiter, ben, de la boisson.
Mh.
Et des eaux internationales où des filles des pays baltes, il suffit de traverser hein, c'est pas... C'est vraiment, c'est le plan beuverie, baise quoi.
Et ça, c'est légal. Je veux dire-
Mh.
Alors, ils ont essayé de résoudre le problème en donnant une omnicompétence aux tribunaux, mais comment est-ce qu'un tribunal suédois pourrait, et ce qui fait d'ailleurs que ça coince, pourrait objectiver que
la personne a été, enfin, aurait l'info déjà, que la personne aurait été voir une prostituée au fin fond de,
d'un pays balte.
Voilà. Et donc en fait, il y a déjà un problème qui est celui-là, c'est que le cas néo-abolitionniste, il tient pas dès qu'on sort un petit peu du territoire.
Et on voit qu'en fait, du coup, le nombre de clients en Suède,
c'est pas clair qu'il ait vraiment diminué. Par contre, les recensements de personnes prostituées montrent une-
Une baisse plutôt du nombre de personnes prostituées, mais une hausse du nombre de personnes qui se prostituent clandestinement, c'est-à-dire dans des conditions vraiment hyper compliquées quoi.
Donc... Et comme
du coup, s'il y a une grosse partie des personnes qui sont dans la clandestinité, on peut aussi supposer qu'il y a une grosse partie qui se déclare pas lorsqu'on fait des enquêtes,
c'est même pas dit qu'on a vraiment une baisse significative de la prostitution en Suède.
Donc ça, c'est Stockholm, les pays nordiques, des exemples de néo-abolitionnisme avec les points faibles que t'as mis en avant.
Si je cherche maintenant à savoir ce que c'est le néo-réglementarisme, de quel côté est-ce que je dois aller chercher ?
Il y a plein de modèles, mais les deux modèles les plus connus, c'est le modèle allemand et le modèle hollandais. Alors même chose Pays-Bas, c'est comme la Belgique, c'est une lasagne institutionnelle.
Donc en fait, c'est difficile de dire qu'il y a un modèle Pays-Bas. En fait, il y a plusieurs modèles et donc il faut là aussi aller voir comment chaque ville s'organise.
C'est clair que les petites villes, historiquement très conservatrices, en fait, il y a quasi pas de prostitution parce qu'ils sont dans des logiques très prohibitionnistes, c'est-à-dire interdiction pure et simple de tout quoi.
Ouais. L'exemple qui revient surtout alors, c'est Amsterdam.
Amsterdam.
La Red Light.
Voilà, oui. Donc évidemment, il y a Amsterdam et Amsterdam, c'est un modèle en soi en fait.
En fait, ce qui est important de pointer à Amsterdam, c'est qu'on est dans un modèle néo-réglementariste où, par rapport au réglementariste historique, qu'est-ce qu'il y a de néo, qu'est-ce qu'il y a de nouveau ?
En fait, on va essayer de reconnaître à la personne qui se prostitue tout un ensemble de droits. Dans l'ordre réglementariste, on s'en moquait un peu des droits de la personne prostituée.
On voulait juste qu'elle soit pas un vecteur de maladie. On voulait juste éviter qu'elle arnaque le client. C'était une préoccupation surtout sur les hommes bourgeois.
Dans le modèle néo, on va commencer à vouloir donner des droits à la personne prostituée. Et donc pour ça, on va lui ouvrir toute une série d'accès au droit du travail.
Et c'est globalement l'approche néerlandaise. C'est aussi globalement l'approche allemande. Et donc, on va pouvoir permettre aux personnes de se déclarer, mais on va aussi du coup les enregistrer.
Et ça veut dire aussi qu'on peut faire un contrôle policier un peu plus facile. Alors là, ce qu'il faut bien pointer par rapport au modèle néo-réglementariste, c'est que c'est vrai qu'il ouvre des droits,
mais il n'ouvre pas, par exemple, la propriété de l'endroit où on se prostitue.
C'est-à-dire, on va être reconnu comme prostituée indépendante, OK, mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on est propriétaire de la vitrine dans laquelle on se prostitue en tant que propriétaire indépendante.
Et ça, ça a fait un truc qui est que, globalement, il y a une hausse terrible des loyers des vitrines sur Amsterdam depuis que les personnes ont pu s'enregistrer comme prostituées indépendantes.
Et donc la municipalité a, dans un premier temps, commencé à développer toute une série d'initiatives en dialogue avec les personnes prostituées qui visaient à, en gros, un système qui s'appelle Eigen Grond, donc ma propre
surface de prostitution. Et donc là, il y a
en fait le modèle néo-réglementariste 2.0, c'est d'aller plus loin que simplement être indépendant, c'est aussi devenir propriétaire de l'endroit où on se prostitue, parce qu'on se rend compte que sinon, en fait,
si on dit juste : vous êtes indépendante, on vous reconnaît le droit du travail, mais qu'en fait, vous êtes pas propriétaire,
immédiatement, en fait,
le fait de reconnaître
bénéficie essentiellement aux propriétaires qui peuvent du coup pratiquer des loyers délirants.
Donc typiquement, c'est 5 000 euros par mois, le fait d'être dans une vitrine dans le quartier rouge aujourd'hui à Amsterdam.
5 000, c'est même pas les centrales, hein, ça peut monter jusqu'à 15 000. Donc le nombre de passes qu'il faut que ces femmes enchaînent pour réussir à payer ça, c'est hallucinant.
La contrepartie du fait de reconnaître à certains des droits, c'est aussi qu'on sort des droits toute une série de personnes.
Et donc historiquement, Amsterdam, qui est la plus libérale des communes hollandaises pour ça, c'est-- il y avait des zones qui étaient les zones tout est toléré.
Donc, il y avait des zones où les personnes pouvaient se prostituer en rue. Il n'y avait aucun problème. Donc c'était vraiment les zones où les personnes avec des graves problèmes d'addiction, vraiment en décrochage, pouvaient aller et se prostituer.
Voilà. Là, c'était toléré. Mais très rapidement, comme ces zones amènent, puisqu'il y a des problèmes d'addiction, puisque du coup, il y a du trafic de drogue, puisque enfin voilà, amènent des nuisances.
Et ça, on n'aime pas les nuisances de manière générale, qu'on soit bourgmestre ou membre d'un conseil communal. Eh ben, forcément,
l'approche a été : puisqu'on a des lieux où on reconnaît des droits, où on enregistre les personnes, où c'est bien contrôlé, on va fermer ces zones de non-droit
qui sont problématiques.
Et en les fermant, en fait, on organise la poursuite de ces personnes. C'est-à-dire que les policiers peuvent aller les choper si elles se prostituent malgré tout en dehors des zones réglementées.
Et donc ce modèle-là, mine de rien, tout comme le néo-abolitionnisme disait : ah ben, oui, les personnes prostituées sont des victimes.
Et puis en fait, on se rend compte que progressivement, dans son implémentation, c'est des victimes, mais on les expulse quand même.
Ici, on est : oui, ce sont des personnes autonomes, on les respecte, etc. M'enfin, on va quand même leur faire des amendes vraiment très très sérieuses si jamais elles sont au mauvais endroit pour se prostituer.
Donc la conclusion à laquelle je veux arriver, c'est qu'en fait, il n'y a pas vraiment un modèle qui soit optimal, en fait,
et que grosso modo, ce qui est toujours sous-jacent à la mise en place par les pouvoirs publics d'un modèle ou d'un autre, c'est plus la volonté de contenir les nuisances
Rassurer le voisinage, encadrer la chose, si possible générer des bénéfices pour l'État, hein,
quitte à éventuellement aller pomper un peu d'argent de l'activité prostitutionnelle, mais c'est rarement, en fait, le bien-être des personnes prostituées.
On, voilà, on évoque ici les différents modèles, les différents modes de réglementation.
Euh, avec, voilà, ça touche à ce que tu expliquais, les cultures peut-être plus protestantes, des cultures plus catholiques qui vont avoir des approches différentes, historiques, et cetera.
Si on revient sur la petite Belgique, historiquement catholique, on peut aussi,
ça arrive souvent, la diviser en deux avec une partie du pays qui va souvent plutôt regarder vers les Pays-Bas et une partie du pays qui va plutôt regarder vers la France.
Est-ce qu'on observe une différence importante entre la façon dont la prostitution est réglementée en Flandre par rapport à la Belgique francophone ?
Alors, en fait, ça se pose pas comme ça. Ça se pose vraiment pas comme ça. C'est amusant parce que c'est un des rares champs où le clivage linguistique est pas si prégnant.
Ça se pose beaucoup plus en termes de proximité. Plus les communes connaissent essentiellement le modèle français, plus elles sont proches du côté francophone, 'fin français, la frontière naturelle française-
D'accord
...plus elles vont être dans un modèle type abolitionniste. Et puis, il y a l'autre axe : plus elles sont proches des Pays-Bas ou de l'Allemagne, plus les communes vont avoir une tendance à être dans le système réglementariste.
D'accord, oui. Que ce soit en Flandre ou en Wallonie.
Que ce soit en Flandre ou en Wallonie. Clairement, la zone autour de Liège regarde plus du côté-- plus on se rapproche, en fait, de Maastricht, plus c'est le modèle Maastricht qui va être déterminant.
Et Liège regarde plus vers Maastricht, ce qui est surprenant, que du côté français. Voilà.
Mh.
Tournai, par contre, regarde beaucoup plus du côté français. Donc ouais, non. Il y a vraiment plus une question de proximité, de qui on joue directement, que de frontière entre Flamands et Francophones.
Avec une exception, c'est globalement à Bruxelles où, de manière générale, les Flamands sont plutôt, les Flamands bruxellois sont beaucoup plus sensibles au modèle anversois, avec la Villa Tinto, et cetera.
Et du côté des francophones, on a une division, un éclatement complet, qui suit même pas les lignes de fracture des partis, hein.
C'est aussi intéressant. C'est qu'il y a pas vraiment de parti qui a une position hyper claire, en fait, sur la question.
Il y a vraiment des lignes de fracture internes.
Tu évoquais tout à l'heure l'idée que, parmi les trois modèles, réglementariste, abolitionniste, et la prohibition, chacun a son lot de problèmes, chacun a ses avantages.
Il y en a pas vraiment un qui-
Il y en a un qui a pas du tout d'avantage, c'est la prohibition.
D'accord, OK. OK.
Ça, il faut le dire, la prohibition, c'est vraiment horrible. La prohibition, c'est le modèle polonais. C'est horrible.
C'est simplement, on interdit aux personnes de se prostituer purement et simplement. On les trouve, on les chope, on les fout en prison, ça ne résout rien, ça rend hyper violent.
Et en plus, clairement, c'est un truc de classe parce qu'en fait, celles qu'on chope, c'est celles qui se prostituent, en fait, dans les endroits populaires.
Parce que quand on se prostitue dans les maisons bourgeoises, on n'est pas chopé. Donc c'est vraiment le pire du pire.
Mais donc, si on revient alors juste sur les deux grands axes, néo-abolitionniste, néo-réglementariste, voilà, difficile de vraiment les départager, 'fin, d'en trouver un qui est vraiment objectivement meilleur que l'autre.
Si je reviens donc encore une fois sur la Belgique, où là, on est dans cette espèce de flou hypocrite que tu as bien décrit tout à l'heure, quelles évolutions est-ce que tu aimerais voir en Belgique ?
Si vu qu'on est dans une espèce de flou hypocrite, qu'une direction comme l'autre pose problème, qu'est-ce que tu aimerais voir comme changement ?
Et attention, surprise, je suis toujours avec toi, Renaud, mais nous avons avancé de deux semaines dans le temps. Je suis retourné voir Renaud parce que le ministre de la Justice, Vincent Van Quickenborne, a justement annoncé
toute une série de réformes concernant, d'une part, les violences sexuelles et d'autre part, justement, la prostitution.
Et du coup, forcément, tout ce segment qu'on a enregistré ensemble concernant la légalité de la prostitution en Belgique, tout ce segment part en fumée, s'évapore.
Il ne vaut plus rien, puisque la question de la légalité de la prostitution va bientôt évoluer en Belgique. Renaud, qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire sur ces nouvelles lois qui vont entrer en vigueur ?
Mais donc, ce que le ministre de la Justice a proposé, c'est une réforme du code pénal. Donc, j'insiste, c'est bien une réforme du code pénal.
C'est pas vraiment une loi sur la prostitution parce qu'il y a un volet très important qui n'est pas du tout abordé, c'est la question des droits sociaux.
C'est-à-dire, il n'est pas question ici, en fait, de donner des droits sociaux ou un accès au droit du travail, par exemple, un accès facilité à la cotisation pour les personnes prostituées.
Donc c'est important de le rappeler parce qu'on a lu assez bien dans la presse que c'était finalement une réforme très ambitieuse qui allait décriminaliser la prostitution complètement, qui allait donner un statut, et cetera.
Non. La seule chose qu'on fait, en fait, c'est qu'on sort un petit peu de l'hypocrisie historique qui consistait à dire, comme on l'avait traité déjà
il y a deux semaines, qui consistait à dire : « En fait, vous pouvez vous prostituer, mais vous pouvez rien faire pour le faire savoir.
Et donc, vous pouvez pas faire votre publicité, vous pouvez pas démarcher dans la rue, vous pouvez... » Voilà. Ça, c'est le point le plus important de cette réforme.
C'est de dire : finalement, si vous vous prostituez et que vous faites la publicité pour vous-même, vous avez l'autorisation de faire cette publicité.
Vous pouvez démarcher pour aller trouver des clients. Donc ça, c'est vraiment la pierre angulaire de cette refonte et c'est quelque chose qui en fait correspond grosso modo à la réalité déjà pratique.
C'est-à-dire il n'y avait plus de poursuites devant les tribunaux des personnes qui faisaient de la publicité sur la prostitution.
La deuxième chose qui est changée, c'est qu'on change tout ce qui concerne le proxénétisme. Le proxénétisme était très durement réprimé par le code pénal, notamment parce qu'il était interdit de tirer profit de la débauche d'autrui.
Bon, alors tout ça est modernisé, on change de vocabulaire pour coller un peu plus au vocabulaire des tribunaux d'aujourd'hui et on
change ça en mettant en exergue l'idée que ce qui est interdit finalement, c'est simplement d'avoir un profit anormal de la débauche d'autrui.
Donc l'idée, c'est de protéger par exemple un propriétaire qui, ben voilà, met un bien en location et puis une personne se prostitue à l'intérieur de ce bien.
C'est vrai que jusque-là, on aurait pu, bon, ça n'arrivait plus non plus, on aurait pu, c'est arrivé dans les années septante par exemple,
poursuivre le propriétaire en disant : bon voilà, vous tirez un profit de la débauche d'autrui puisque vous tirez via votre loyer en fait
un profit de la prostitution de la personne qui se prostitue dans votre bien.
Voilà. Ici, le propriétaire sera protégé s'il pratique un loyer correct. Voilà. Alors il y a quand même un problème là-derrière, c'est que la notion de profit anormal, elle fait l'objet d'un débat assez intense de la jurisprudence.
Les tribunaux sont pas d'accord entre eux, les magistrats sont très très partagés et c'est une base qui rend très difficile en fait le fait de poursuivre vraiment un proxénète.
C'est-à-dire que comme la notion de profit anormal n'est pas claire dans la jurisprudence, qu'il y a pas de niveau, on définit pas c'est X % de, il y a pas de barème si on veut.
Ben du coup en fait, c'est vrai que ça ouvre une véritable difficulté pour la poursuite des proxénètes sur base des profits qu'ils génèrent.
Parce que c'est quoi un profit anormal ? Est-ce que si je mets en location une carrée à Saint-Josse à cinq mille euros, c'est vraiment complètement anormal.
Un propriétaire pourra arguer que c'est finalement le prix des carrés et que vu qu'en plus il y a une taxe communale, ben voilà, il faut bien qu'il rembourse la taxe communale.
Et là vraiment, en fait, on voit qu'on fragilise un peu les outils de lutte contre le proxénétisme. Alors c'est problématique pour lutter contre le proxénétisme.
Ceci dit, ça met à l'abri tout plein de situations où en fait, on n'est pas dans des situations de proxénétisme. J'ai évoqué le propriétaire qui met un bien en location et qui sait pas spécialement ce qui s'y passe.
Ça, toutes ces situations-là sont régularisées. On sort d'un système qui était très hypocrite et assez daté.
Pour autant, c'est pas non plus, on n'est pas dans la grande refonte que les médias et le ministre nous vendent. On est quand même dans quelque chose d'assez modeste.
On n'a pas d'accès, je le répète, au volet social. Il y a vraiment pas eu de travail sur la question de droit social et il y a pas eu de réflexion approfondie sur finalement
non plus comment est-ce qu'on pourrait accompagner cette réforme du code pénal au niveau de tout ce qui est, ben, suivi des victimes de traite.
Voilà, alors ça, c'est quand même un truc sur lequel la Belgique reste un peu en retard. Et puis toutes les personnes qui veulent sortir de la prostitution.
On n'avance pas là-dessus, on n'investit pas dans ce qu'on appelle les programmes de sortie, etc. Là aussi, voilà, c'est un grand chantier qui reste à faire.
Et donc finalement, c'est vraiment une réformette. En fait, c'est une mise à jour qui correspond à une pratique saine des tribunaux qui permettra d'éviter certains excès.
Faut pas non plus dire que d'un coup la Belgique est devenue réglementariste comme on a pu le lire.
C'est ça. Mais par contre, ce qui me surprend, c'est que j'avais justement cru comprendre que les prostituées pouvaient désormais se déclarer auprès des institutions type CPAS, aide sociale, cotisations pour les pensions, etc.
Est-ce que j'ai mal compris ? Est-ce qu'il y a vraiment eu aucune évolution à ce niveau-là ?
L'ouverture du code pénal permet théoriquement la création de catégories. Elle ne le permet pas en pratique, parce qu'en pratique, il faut qu'il y ait un texte de loi qui concerne spécifiquement le droit du travail, le droit social.
Et ça, on n'y est pas encore. En fait, la réforme du code pénal ne va dramatiquement changer la situation au niveau des communes, à part que certaines communes utilisaient dans leur règlement qui réprimait la prostitution,
des dispositions inspirées par le code pénal.
En disant, ben voilà, nous dans notre règlement,
vu qu'il y a le code pénal qui interdit l'incitation à la
débauche, ben dans notre règlement de police, on va mettre que ça, c'est vraiment un truc qui n'est pas acceptable pour nous et donc on va autoriser les agents de quartier à venir faire des contrôles parce que c'est
finalement la stricte application de ce que le code pénal dit.
Aujourd'hui, il y aura plus cet argument-là, mais on peut trouver plein d'autres arguments. On peut trouver l'argument de, par exemple, la tranquillité publique.
Ce qui est vraiment un changement important, et ça, c'est quand même vraiment l'avancée positive majeure, c'est vraiment cette question de la publicité.
C'est de dire : ben une personne qui se prostitue aujourd'hui et qui fait la publicité du fait qu'elle se prostitue ne pourra plus être poursuivie.
Et ça, c'est quand même vraiment une avancée positive parce que, de fait, c'était quand même une épée de Damoclès qui,
qui pesait au-dessus de la tête des personnes qui se prostituaient, même si en pratique, très peu, très peu, très très peu de poursuites hein.
Mais voilà. Donc ça, c'est quand même quelque chose de positif. Mais c'est loin d'être la révolution.
Oui. Donc loin d'être la révolution, quelques idées positives, mais globalement, je retiens surtout le mot réforme. Merci beaucoup Renaud pour cette update et on retourne à présent à notre entretien dans le passé.
Moi, je fais partie des gens qui considèrent qu'on ne peut pas résoudre le problème de la prostitution. Poser la chose comme ça, c'est une mauvaise manière de voir.
Et donc je pense pas qu'en fait la solution soit une position abolitionniste, réglementariste. Je pense pas que ce soit juste les évolutions du cadre légal qui vont solutionner
toutes les différentes problématiques qui se posent dans toutes les formes de prostitution et qui sont chaque fois différentes.
Je pense qu'il faut revenir chaque fois au terrain, regarder chaque situation et en fonction de chaque situation, il faut concevoir des dispositifs un peu intelligents.
La première chose qui me semble évidente, c'est que pour toute une série de personnes, la prostitution, c'est un choix contraint.
Et ça, ça pose un problème. Effectivement, c'est très anormal que des personnes aient cette activité-là alors qu'elles ont pas envie de l'avoir.
Elles se sentent mal avec ça. 'fin voilà. Mais donc, comment est-ce qu'on lève cette contrainte ? Est-ce que c'est par le cadre légal ?
Je pense, très honnêtement, pas vraiment. Ce qui va permettre d'ouvrir ces problématiques et de travailler là-dessus, c'est tout le travail d'accompagnement vers, ben ouvrir d'autres possibilités pour ces personnes.
Qu'elles n'aient plus de problèmes de droit de séjour, par exemple. Mais donc ça veut dire travailler sur les politiques d'asile.
Qu'elles n'aient plus de conflit avec le CPAS. Ça veut dire travailler sur les politiques d'intégration sociale. Qu'elles n'aient pas de problème à reprendre des études et à obtenir un diplôme.
Ça veut dire travailler sur toutes les politiques d'accès à l'enseignement et à l'enseignement supérieur. Toutes des thématiques où on est très mauvais en Belgique.
Donc voilà, on a une politique d'asile et d'immigration qui est de plus en plus restrictive, qui est vraiment une politique radine d'accueil vraiment hyper, hyper limitée.
On a une politique
de lutte contre la pauvreté qui est globalement relativement inefficace, avec un dispositif d'intégration sociale
où on exclut de plus en plus de personnes avec toutes les réformes de l'intégration sociale depuis 2002, qui sont vraiment une machine à exclure toute une série de personnes.
Et donc on précarise des gens et en plus en particulier les femmes et en particulier les femmes célibataires avec charge d'enfant.
Et en matière d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur, on a le système d'enseignement supérieur et même d'enseignement secondaire le plus inégalitaire de l'ensemble des pays de l'OCDE.
Donc voilà. Donc voilà, ça, c'est les grands chantiers politiques si on veut vraiment résoudre la problématique de... voilà.
Les problématiques liées à la prostitution sont plutôt symptomatiques d'une série d'inégalités sociales.
Mais oui, oui. Et donc c'est très facile aussi de poser la question de savoir : est-ce qu'on va plutôt faire un règlement ou est-ce qu'on va plutôt criminaliser les clients, etc.
Parce qu'en fait, ça permet toujours d'éviter le débat de fond qui est : comment cette machine prostitutionnelle, elle est alimentée.
Et elle est alimentée par toute une série de mécanismes qui sont, ben, notamment les politiques d'asile et d'immigration, les politiques d'accès à l'éducation, les politiques de redistribution, les politiques d'accès à l'aide sociale, etc.
Et donc pour moi, l'enjeu premier et la première évolution et ce pour quoi je milite activement, c'est d'ouvrir
des dispositifs qui sont les dispositifs de sortie volontaire, c'est-à-dire où on n'impose pas que pour suivre, tu dois renoncer entièrement à l'activité prostitutionnelle,
gérer dans des mécanismes de compagnonnage, c'est-à-dire où t'as pas un travailleur social tout seul qui t'explique comment tu dois faire, mais t'as aussi des personnes ex-prostituées ou
qui sont informées de la situation des personnes prostituées.
'fin voilà. Et où on ouvre un maximum de perspectives. Parce que clairement, dans certaines situations prostitutionnelles, si je prends la prostitution de bas, on peut quand même cumuler des revenus relativement importants
et proposer comme alternative à ces revenus importants un job de merde dans le repassage industriel.
Bah oui, effectivement, les femmes, elles vont pas dire : « Ah oui, super », quoi. Par contre, bah oui, on peut imaginer qu'on fasse tout pour que des personnes prostituées puissent devenir magistrate, politicienne.
Voilà, ça, c'est une perspective. Un peu d'ambition.
Ce ne sera pas simple.
C'est pas simple, mais en même temps, ça fonctionne hein, c'est...
Finalement, s'il y a un truc qu'il faut se souvenir du succès du néoabolitionnisme suédois, là où il y a eu vraiment des succès, c'est dans tout leur programme d'action sociale hein.
Le déploiement des refuges. Alors évidemment, quand la droite est arrivée au pouvoir, elle a sabré dans tout ça. Mais le développement des refuges, c'était vraiment pas con.
Ce qui marche dans le modèle néo-réglementariste à Amsterdam, c'est les associations d'anciennes prostituées et prostitués qui se sont mis ensemble pour faire des ateliers collectifs.
Ça, ça marche super bien. Et donc en fait, il y a des trucs qu'on peut retenir dans ces modèles, mais généralement, c'est tout ce qui est le travail social, le travail collectif, tout ce qui est animation de première ligne.
C'est pas les grands principes abstraits et leur traduction juridique qui est souvent après récupérée dans des politiques qui se préoccupent pas du tout des personnes prostituées.
Et donc prendre le bout sous l'angle du travail collectif, travail d'accompagnement, travail social. C'est ça pour moi qui est la clé quoi.
Mais ça veut pas dire envoyer un travailleur social du CPAS qui va expliquer que c'est très très mal de se prostituer, et que maintenant il faut-
S'isoler de ce milieu absolument et ne plus jamais le voir, c'est un truc que je pointais dans un papier, c'est que c'est un discours qu'on a souvent auprès des personnes prostituées.
« Ah, tu veux sortir de la prostitution ? Oui, mais alors tu ne vois plus du tout personne dans l'entourage prostitutionnel.
» Évidemment, on désocialise les gens et puis après, on s'étonne qu'ils craquent complètement et qu'ils reviennent à l'activité prostitutionnelle.
C'est dégueulasse de désocialiser quelqu'un. Sans compter en plus qu'il y a des mécanismes de pairage, même dans les conditions les plus trash à Isère, il y a des personnes prostituées qui s'épaulent les unes les autres.
Elles s'aident par rapport aux clients violents. Elles s'aident aussi à tenir le coup au niveau du contrôle sur la consommation.
Parce que bon, pour celles qui sont vraiment très tox, entre elles, en fait, elles se contrôlent pour voir qu'il y en ait pas une qui prenne trop quoi.
Mais donc dès qu'on va isoler cette personne de toutes ses amies qui l'aident à contrôler, elle sait plus gérer sa consommation forcément, puisque son garde-fou, il est là.
Et donc là aussi, il n'y a pas d'action collective vis-à-vis des personnes prostituées. Il y a très peu d'action collective auprès des personnes prostituées. C'est hallucinant.
Sur base de ce flou juridique en Belgique, cette situation hypocrite,
ce que tu dis, c'est : il y a peut-être moyen de construire sur ce néant, pour dire ça comme ça, et s'inspirer, voilà, de ce qu'il y a à retenir d'un côté comme de l'autre, d'Amsterdam comme de Stockholm.
Mais ça veut dire refuser les solutions simples-
Ouais, ouais
...refuser le système concentrationnaire. On va faire un gros center, on va toutes les mettre dedans, ça va tout résoudre.
Toutes ces idées de politiciens un peu débiles et qui sont vraiment problématiques parce que là aussi, 'fin,
l'idée, on va mettre toutes les personnes prostituées dans un machin bien clos, bien dans un coin comme ça personne, ça dérange personne,
c'est évidemment aussi, ben les retirer de la rue, donc
empêcher tout ce qui leur permet de faire autre chose en fait.
Un dernier angle qu'on n'a pas encore abordé et qui est pourtant très important en ce qui concerne la prostitution, c'est ce nouvel outil, ce petit bazar qui s'appelle Internet.
Qu'est-ce que Internet a pu changer vis-à-vis du métier, voilà, des travailleuses du sexe ?
Ben en fait, ça dépend quelle forme de prostitution on regarde. Parce que si on prend vraiment la prostitution de carré, hyper tradi, ça change pas grand-chose.
Ça a changé là parce qu'il y avait une crise et donc ça a été le lieu refuge pour finalement quand même trouver des clients.
Ouais, ouais, pendant la pandémie, oui.
Mais sinon, ça change pas grand-chose. Par contre, si on prend,
si on prend, ben, en dehors des carrés, si on prend la prostitution de rue, etc, c'est clair que pour celles des personnes prostituées qui ont les codes, parce qu'elles n'ont pas toutes les codes,
c'est devenu le lieu privilégié, en fait, de déploiement de l'activité prostitutionnelle avec cette facilité pour les clients, voilà, qui du coup doivent pas faire des démarches de négociation et tout ça.
Tout ça se fait en amont avec la protection de leur anonymat, potentiellement. Donc oui, c'est une évolution majeure. Il y a trois trucs qui sont évidents.
C'est, un, c'est plus facile de se prostituer via Internet que de se mettre dans la rue ou de se mettre dans un carré. Bon voilà, c'est...
Donc potentiellement, ça peut faciliter l'entrée en prostitution. La deuxième chose, c'est que ça facilite le contact avec les clients qui effectivement doivent pas s'afficher dans la rue, etc.
Donc, ouais. Et alors la troisième chose, c'est que ça facilite aussi la question du, comment je dirais-
De l'exploitation, du tirer profit.
Oui, voilà, c'est plus facile en fait de tirer profit d'une activité lorsque elle se développe sur Internet parce qu'elle est vraiment très confidentielle.
Mh.
Il y a beaucoup moins de contrôle, je sais pas, de la brigade des mœurs ou même des associations de terrain. Ça s'échappe à tout le monde en fait.
Les plateformes peuvent se trouver dans les Caraïbes, sur une île.
Ouais, en particulier, oui. Et alors bon, il faut quand même pointer qu'en fait, il y a un truc que personne ne dit, c'est que
les plateformes qui ont de la prostitution, qui organisent la prostitution vraiment et qui le savent, même si elles appellent ça parfois du sugar dating, etc.
En fait, le gros de leur modèle financier repose pas sur l'activité prostitutionnelle elle-même. Elles prennent relativement...
Bon elles font payer la création du profil tout ça, mais en fait, c'est pas énorme. Ce qu'elles font avant tout, elles exposent à de la pub.
Mh.
Et donc il y a un jeu très très drôle de ces plateformes qui est de faire des campagnes dont elles savent pertinemment bien qu'elles passeront très très mal et qu'elles vont susciter des tollés.
On l'a vu notamment avec une campagne qui a été faite il y a quelques années par un site de sugar dating.
À l'ULB.
À l'ULB. Enfin, c'était prévu de le faire sur plusieurs campus et ils l'ont fait dans plusieurs pays. Avec l'idée, le message, c'était : étudiant, tu vas arrondir tes fins de mois.
Ben voilà. Et en fait, c'est fascinant parce qu'en fait,
ces plateformes ont obtenu ce qu'elles voulaient, à savoir qu'elles ont eu plein de personnes qui se sont inscrites suite à ça sur ce site, en ce compris des journalistes qui ont été étudiés hein, pour voir comment ça fonctionnait et tout ça.
Mais en fait, cette inscription massive a fait qu'elles ont généré des revenus publicitaires vachement plus supérieurs.
Et donc en fait, elles se sont très joliment enrichies, ce qui leur permet par ailleurs du coup de payer facilement leur procès.
Et donc ça, il faut pas oublier, il faut pas croire dans le mythe complet qu'en fait, ce serait juste du proxénétisme.
En fait, c'est plus des annonceurs que des proxénètes. C'est un truc qui est important à garder en tête.
Mais un truc qui a changé du coup, forcément, et ça, c'est vraiment un souci mine de rien, c'est que ça individualise beaucoup plus la relation prostitutionnelle, mine de rien, le fait de passer par un site.
C'est un truc que dans mes travaux sur la prostitution étudiante, j'ai pointé. On croit souvent que la prostitution étudiante, comme c'est des étudiants, tout ça, en fait, finalement, ce serait moins glauque, moins violent, moins dangereux, etc,
que la prostitution dans un quartier un peu délabré, voilà.
Mais en fait, comme elles sont seules avec le client, il y a pas tous les mécanismes de pairage qu'on peut avoir dans la rue.
Donc par exemple, le fait de détecter un client violent, comme je disais tout à l'heure, c'est pas quelque chose que, ah ben tiens, elles savent pas entre elles puisque elles sont chacune avec leur profil, etc.
Et donc y a en fait plus de violence potentiellement, plus de danger dans cette relation individuelle. En ajoutant en plus le fait que le lieu de rencontre souvent pour la prostitution sur Internet, c'est soit chez le client,
soit chez la personne prostituée quoi.
Éventuellement à l'hôtel pour celles qui savent qu'il faut pas trop prendre de risques, mais mine de rien, c'est assez rapidement, on rentre rapidement chez soi ou chez le client.
Et ça, c'est quand même super risqué comme type de dispositif.
Ouais, ouais. Un autre phénomène dont tu as pu parler dans tes travaux de recherche, c'est le concept de décorporalisation.
Est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer de quoi il s'agit ?
La notion de décorporalisation-
On va pas s'y agir
C'est une notion qu'on doit à Judith Trincard, qui est médecin et qui s'est intéressée à des personnes prostituées, mais vraiment dans des situations très trash.
Donc des, avec des problèmes d'addiction, avec prostitution de rue, dans des, en plus des villes où les quartiers de prostitution sont vraiment délabrés.
Donc, on est quand même sur un public très spécifique. Et en fait, qu'est-ce qu'elle constate ? Elle constate, c'est une forme de discours de dissociation où ces personnes n'investissent plus du tout leur corps
et vivent l'activité comme une série de,
de, oui, d'agressions perpétuelles de leur corps, mais comme elles sont plus du tout dedans, c'est comme si elles réfugiaient leur esprit ailleurs et donc elles abandonnent complètement le soin d'elles-mêmes.
Elles sont plus du tout incarnées. Et donc le résultat de ça, c'est que, ben voilà, elles laissent leur corps aller complètement, avec tous les problèmes de santé qu'elles peuvent avoir, avec des traces de violence.
Elles encaissent des coups, c'est pas grave, de toute façon. Enfin, voilà. Donc c'est vraiment un phénomène de désincarnation de son propre corps.
Alors, l'hypothèse de Judith Trincard, c'est de dire : c'est un trait commun aux personnes prostituées de manière générale.
Et c'est là où, enfin, c'est pas vraiment elle qui le dit, c'est surtout les gens qui utilisent ces travaux, mais c'est là où je pense qu'il faut faire très attention parce que c'est pas forcément aussi évident.
C'est-à-dire que cette décorporalisation, elle existe pas forcément dans toutes les situations de prostitution, dans toutes les formes de prostitution.
Et surtout, en fait, il faut se méfier de cette notion parce que très facilement, on peut établir une forme de grille diagnostique où on regarde chaque symptôme
un à un et puis on coche et on se dit : « Ah ben si la personne, elle coche tous les symptômes, c'est qu'elle est dans un état de décorporéisation.
» Or, parmi les symptômes qui sont communément admis, il y a l'idée, par exemple, de dire : « En fait, je vis l'activité comme un spectacle.
Je ne suis pas incarné, c'est pas vraiment moi au moment où je me prostitue.
» Mais ça, je suis pas sûr qu'en fait, ce soit en soi la preuve qu'on est dans un rapport traumatique au corps où on décorporélise complètement, on se sort de son propre corps.
On peut être très incarné et jouer un autre rôle. Il y a pour moi une grande différence entre faire un jeu d'acteur et ne plus du tout sentir son corps.
Un acteur, il sent son corps, même quand il fait un personnage. Et dans la prostitution, de fait, il y a un jeu d'acteur qui est assez fréquent.
Ça veut pas dire que forcément les personnes qui sont dans ce jeu d'acteur sont pas dans leur corps. Au contraire, elles peuvent être très forts dans leur corps.
Moi, ce que j'ai rencontré aussi, beaucoup, c'est des personnes prostituées qui disent que, par l'activité prostitutionnelle, elles prennent soin de leur corps comme jamais, en fait.
Elles sont dans leur corps comme jamais parce que c'est une activité qui est quand même très physique, qui nécessite de continuer à plaire, donc qui nécessite d'être très fort dans son corps tout le temps, de le maîtriser, de l'entretenir.
Et donc, je pense qu'il faut se méfier, en fait, de cette hypothèse qui est très cohérente dans les cas de prostitution les plus extrêmes et certainement très valable dans les cas plus spécifiquement de traite.
Mais le généraliser, c'est assez dangereux parce que ça revient très facilement à l'idée de la putain dégénérée. On retombe dans cette bonne vieille idée : « Ah oui, c'est la putain dégénérée.
» Et je pense que c'est vraiment une image fausse et c'est une image extrêmement stigmatisante.
Renaud, on arrive au bout des septante minutes. Est-ce qu'il reste un sujet, un angle que tu aimerais aborder, un message que tu aimerais faire passer de manière plus générale au sujet, voilà, de la prostitution ?
Ben, moi, ce qui m'importerait, ce à quoi j'ai envie d'inviter toute personne qui écoute ce podcast, c'est vraiment que les gens travaillent sur leurs représentations par rapport aux personnes prostituées.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils aient pas peur parce qu'il y a une personne qui se prostitue à proximité, qu'ils changent leur regard simplement en se disant : « Ben en fait, c'est une personne humaine qui fait ça.
Suffit de lui parler et en fait, ça va bien se passer. » Je pense qu'on est resté coincé dans un schéma hallucinant où finalement, on nie l'humanité des personnes qui se prostituent.
Et je comprends pas que ça puisse perdurer aujourd'hui
et c'est vraiment un enjeu. Et à plus forte raison, j'aimerais que les politiciens soient dans la même logique, que plutôt que de penser
ex abstracto les politiques publiques, ils prennent le temps de parler, discuter, d'écouter les personnes prostituées, toutes les personnes prostituées dans
l'entièreté des situations très compliquées dans lesquelles elles sont, ce qui veut dire effectivement faire beaucoup de réunions et faire un vrai travail.
Mais je pense que c'est tellement important pour prendre des politiques publiques qui fassent sens que voilà, c'est indispensable en fait.
Donc ouais, l'enjeu, c'est simplement les visibiliser, leur permettre de parler et leur donner des espaces, quoi, d'écoute et de dialogue.
Super. Renaud, merci beaucoup. Est-ce qu'il y a un endroit où les auditeurs, les auditrices peuvent te retrouver, te lire, te suivre sur Internet ?
Ben, ils peuvent me suivre sur Twitter ou Facebook, ça marche toujours assez bien, mais sinon,
qu'ils s'abonnent au site de la Revue Nouvelle, voire même à la Revue Nouvelle, excellente revue, parce que l'essentiel de mes productions se retrouve dans la revue.
Renaud, encore une fois, merci.
Merci à toi.
Et on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode. Au revoir.
À bientôt.
Voilà, j'espère que mon entretien avec Renaud vous a plu. Si vous écoutez ce Septante Minutes Avec, je présume que les questions sociopolitiques vous intéressent un minimum.
Donc encore une fois, je ne peux que vous conseiller de checker la Revue Nouvelle. Le lien est en description.
Si tout se passe bien, dans deux semaines, je reçois normalement un écologiste français bien connu, Jean-Marc Jancovici, avec qui on parlera de décroissance, de nucléaire, etc.
Ça s'annonce super. Donc, pour ne pas louper ça, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée ainsi que sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont en description. Je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut !